over centuries the Irish built a rich
heritage of castles and monuments using
an abundance of local stone now many of
the structures are damaged the stone is
decaying thanks in part to Ireland's
notoriously damp weather these sites are
in danger of disappearing entirely this
Tower in western county galway is all
that's left of what was once a fortress
the family that's owned it for
generations now faces a one and a half
million dollar restoration bill and
grants from the state will cover only 2%
of that the psyche is often the ocean
yeah and doesn't come pint is really
making 32,000 you were available for
something that's estimated it'll cost a
million pounds and delays and financing
only need more time for nature to erode
and nation's treasures at the
state-owned religious site of Kwan
makhno Z architects have replaced two
historic stone crosses with replicas
putting the originals away to protect
them from further erosion they recently
put a whole church under wraps but this
kind of protection is costly and
impossible on a wide scale heritage
Council report suggests that there could
be a more practical way we will have to
keep working to see what other methods
of intervention can be brought in into
place it will never stop decay but at
least it may hopefully arrest
stopping the decay is the goal of
conservationists nurturing the clon firt
cathedral the church itself can't afford
to replace the open water joints where
water has entered and caused major
deterioration in the sandstone so a
heritage Council grant has helped start
restoration work on this 12th century
Romanesque doorway getting some leaching
from this one some previous restorations
have done more harm than good we have
here evidence of mortar
repairs which contain Portland cement an
ingredient used in concrete and mortars
has accelerated structural damage to
many stones in a race against the
elements masons are now replacing it
with a better line based mortar some
architects are worried about cheap and
untested alternatives but government
grants for restoration projects are
scarce the Heritage Council says that
without new methods and new sources of
money a vital part of Irish culture will
simply crumble away